OK, let's go next. Let's go to Thibeault from
Belgium, Thibeault from Belgium. You're on
the air. Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I
can. We're in Belgium. Are you calling from.
I am calling from Gunz.
Oh, beautiful, beautiful city. I've been there.
Oh, Nicias is the largest student
population over there. So I'm still studying
veterinary medicine, so that's why I'm there.
Now, Ghent is the one that has the trolley, right?
Trolly, yeah, isn't there
isn't there like an elevated
subway that goes down the streets in Ghent or
is that Antwerp now? It's all blending together.
I think you might confuse confused with anywhere.
OK, all right. Well, I apologize for that.
No problem. So I wanted to ask you because I
have heard I've been following your child for
a couple of months right now. And I was wondering,
because you have always stated that your position
on Trump getting into prison after
his presidency is very minimal, but.
Elsewhere, I've been following the news for
like the past couple of years about Trump and
the difference I am noticing with European
countries is that you have one major news
channel like Fox News enabling his presidency and
his misinformation and his lies. And that is not
something we see here and European countries
where opinion shows don't really exist or not
in such a big fashion as it does in the US. So
I'm thinking Trump has set a precedent right now
by committing crimes inside the White House,
outside the White House, and he can get away with
anything he wants. But the president has already
said so if he runs again in twenty twenty four or
if a more intelligent person, a rich guy with
more intellectual capabilities than Trump
runs in 2020 for the president is set and he can
expand his crimes, he can expand his behavior. So
I think it is important that if Trump is proven
to be guilty of crimes after he leaves the White
House, he should be prosecuted. And if judge
thinks he should go that he should go to jail,
then I think you should not prohibit that or think
of it as he is a former president so we can do it.
Oh, I. I completely agree with you. What I've
said is I don't believe Trump is going to prison.
Your analysis is spot on. Donald Trump has debased
the office of the presidency. He's shown that even
the checks and balances that the founders put in
place never assumed someone who would flout these
norms the way that Donald Trump did. And I believe
that what Donald Trump exposed is that our checks
and balances are not nearly as rigorous as we
imagine them. To be accurate, your assessment is
one hundred percent correct. I just don't believe
there is really any appetite at the top level in
the United States to jail former presidents,
period, that I was making a prediction, not an
analysis. Your analysis is completely correct.
OK, and I'm also worried because
a lot of Democrats, I feel like in the US are
feeling like a democracy is saved right now.
But if Trump is going to start his own news
channel and the Republican Party, by the way,
doesn't exist anymore, it's not a Trump
party. So if they follow his like Trump News
and all of his new opinion shows, he will
launch. And the widespread misinformation then
is going to be like 2016 all over again. I see.
Like I think you're right. And the issue of
whether the Republican Party is now simply the
Trump Party, I think it remains to be seen. I,
I do think that if Donald Trump relatively
quickly goes back into obscurity, which he
may well, we just don't know yet. I think you
will very quickly see a lot of people in the
Republican Party just sort of pretend it never
happened and go back to talking about the debt and
kind of the way the Republican Party was
before Trump. If Trump remains present,
if he starts a news network or whatever the case
may be, I think it'll be handled differently.
I think we just have to wait and see on that.
Mm hmm. Yeah, but the fact that, like 80
percent of Republicans already think that this
election is rigged. Yeah. Also says a lot about.
Yes. A Republican or just. That doesn't bode well.
That doesn't bode well. I agree with you.
OK, thanks for taking my
call. I really appreciate it.
All right, my pleasure. Great to hear
from our friends in Belgium. Belgium is
one of my favorite places I visited. I have to
tell you, I've been to Brussels, Brugge, Ghent
and Antwerp and all. All amazing
places. Really, really great places.